uh but fasten your seat belts can be hot
and humid right now my next guest
because it's someone who normally has
something very well worth listening to
you ever sorry we got married every
second of my life she's the world's most
canceled comic if you just feel like you
can't say it well the chances are
Roseanne Barr's probably already said it
I think [__] to you at all
and lately I've been getting her into a
whole lot of trouble
nobody died in the Holocaust either six
million Jews should die right now but it
never happened
the Jewish comic is accused of being
homophobic transphobic even anti-semitic
and was sensation he dropped from her
own sitcoms for racist Twigs
fancy she's misunderstood critics say
she's missing her marbles at franaganti
protects Me From Myself Tonight I say
she's unsensitive
[Music]
to say I'm joined live from Texas by the
host of the Roseanne Barr podcast it's
Roseanne Roseanne how are you
I'm great how are you pierce well I
can't think of anybody I would rather
have on a show called uncensored than
you
of course you're smart
have we gone mad Roseanne in our world
when I look at all the Fallout to the
things that you say or do
um I look at the sort of apoplexy that
people bring to jokes to humor to
sarcasm to irony all these things and I
I really despair the very essence of
Comedy for example is being expunged
from human life
yes it is uh yeah well you should
despair peers and so should anybody who
has a brain or um you know any Humanity
whatsoever or any connection to any
other human beings on Earth they should
despair too
um I say that they are weaponizing
stupidity and people have sunk to such a
level level that they can't handle
satire because satire is when you take
two disparate subjects and bring them
together to defamiliar de-familiarize
reality such as a poet does with words
familiarize
reality and they cannot hold two
disparate ideas in their head at the
same time because they're fed [__]
24 7 over the media and I'm about to go
crazy sitting here on the earphone
hearing the stuff you all are saying
about the Ukraine I'm about to have a
heart attack but I'm not even going to
go into it I'm from the Ukraine the
Ukrainian the Ukrainian there is a large
faction of Nazis I don't know if you
know this but there's a large amount of
Nazis in the Ukraine and they actually
killed my whole family I'm from the
Ukraine and they marched my entire
family grandmothers
10 siblings out into the forest and
buried them alive in the Ukraine so I
don't understand why everybody's Ukraine
you could well I do understand and
that's also what terrifies me people
better wake up and do some research on
their own instead of buying what comes
across on the screen and I try to shake
them up pierce your goddamn right I do I
try to shake them up and crack their
their mind control programming I do it
for God
well here's resent what I would say to
that I don't agree with you uh about a
lot of the stuff you said about Ukraine
I know what you said and you're
perfectly entitled to your views I would
say in relation to the suggestion that
they're all a bunch of numbers
himself is Jewish so obviously he is de
facto not an answer I know but he's not
a good one or or all Jews are the same
for God's sake talk about anti-semitis
Jew doesn't mean he likes Jews or that
he's doing anything good for the Jews I
mean so what who cares what anybody is
that was the whole point of my tweet
just because they're just because their
skin folk don't mean they're kin folk
you know what I mean just because
they're the same colors you don't mean
they ain't trying to lock your ass up
wake up people
out of it
okay listen like I said you're
uncensored so you're perfectly entitled
to your views I'm entitled to a
different view I'm sure you would accept
that it's okay you've got to be nice to
get your purpose you have a different
view peers I can speak respectfully to
another human being because I actually
you know I love to converse and I just
get passionate sometimes and I I love
that people disagree with me I love to
have conversations
so excuse me
it's okay like cool Sebastian's fine
there was a a big outcry recently where
I defended you actually uh were you
recused of I know you didn't mind you I
was shocked
right well you know I I call things as I
see them and on that occasion it was
clear to me that you were saying a
statement which you didn't actually mean
to be taken literally you were exposing
a wider picture yeah
yeah and the fact that it went over
everybody's head isn't my fault
well I'm going to play it let's play a
clip again to remind people of what got
you into trouble then I'll come and say
what I think about it be sure to be sure
to include the context which was there's
no way in hell Biden got 81 million
votes if you don't include that context
you're going to make me mad peers okay
well it'll make you mad but we've got a
14. we have a 42 second clip let's take
a look
the election was not rigged 36 counties
can give you 81 million both right
that's a fact
so it wasn't rigged of course not yeah
36 Counties have 81 million people in
there see
that's the truth and don't you dare say
anything against it or you'll be off
YouTube Facebook Twitter and all the
other ones because we have you know
there's such a thing as the truth and
facts and we have to stick to it and um
you know it's scary
and that is the truth and nobody died in
the Holocaust either that's the truth
yeah it should happen if six million
Jews should die right now because they
cause all the problems in the world but
it never happened but it never happened
now I listen to that in full context I
listen to a lot more of it and it was
absolutely crystal clear and obvious to
me that you didn't mean anything that
you were saying that in fact you met
that you meant the complete opposite but
it was sliced and diced and put out on
social media and then the next thing is
you have you Roseanne Barr who is
actually Jewish being accused of denying
the Holocaust which obviously is
ridiculous why do these things happen
yeah
um because I'm I'm a targeted individual
as I say you know for 6 000 years there
has been a Jewish Civil War and nobody
knows about it and I speak about it a
lot but it's uh you know it's at its
climax right now and I have been
targeted by you know largely Jewish
people on the other side of the
political Spectrum our view is centered
on whether Israel should exist or not
and these are things we don't talk about
in public but when I ran for president
in 2012 they used to stand up and it was
always Jewish people with silver
ponytails marxists you know if it was
stand up I ran as a socialist and they
would set up and scream what about the
illegal occupation of blah blah and I I
couldn't believe it because they would
do it over and over and over again uh to
attack me because I'm a Jew I think but
Marxist Jews are not the same as the
kind of Jew I am and that's what really
makes me mad because when people assume
that there's only one kind of Jew
they're missing a shitload of history
and I feel like you know I'm here to
is speak to that and also the context
that I used was about the internet is
full of Holocaust denial Nazi comments
and saying but the thing they always say
is no Jews were killed in the Holocaust
but it should happen that's what they
all say and it's all over big shoot
comments YouTube It's wall-to-wall
that's why I left Facebook it made me so
sick it was wall-to-wall anti-Semitism
and um these same people these
socialists aging socialists which I
won't even go into what a scam socialism
is I've talked about that on online a
lot but anyway
um you know they they have made me their
Target because they don't think that I'm
the right kind of Jew and they don't
think that any Jew who thinks like I do
is the right kind of Jew and so I have
to live with that and it is within my
community and it's just like when black
uh people black activists come and talk
about you know being targeted by their
own Community too it's much the same
it's a cultural war and it is between uh
you know the uh far left and normal sane
human beings such as myself
well Roseanne I don't think any of us
are normal scene in human beings my
theory is we're all slightly nuts and
it's just a question of degree but
that's just a personal view uh we can
take a short break when we come back I'm
going to ask you the most contention
but we're going to ask I'm going to ask
you the most controversial I'm going to
ask you the most controversial question
in the world
tell me the joke after the break we'll
be back in two seconds welcome back to
Piers Morgan uncensored live from New
York it's one of the most famous sites
in the world of course I'm still with me
the world's most canceled comedian which
is still there Roseanne barter Rosemary
left viewers on a cliffhanger you were
about to tell me a joke
yeah when I wanted to say two things one
is we have a joke those of us who have
mental health issues that there's insane
and out saying
so I wanted to cap off what you were
saying before but also I wanted to
finish saying that just last week these
leftists such as are in the Biden
Administration the state department of
the United States instituted a boycott
divest and sanction against the Jewish
people in in Israel and also with
American businesses who do
trading business with Israel so it's a
boycott of Israel and of America the
Biden Administration State Department so
there is never an end to uh their
censorship their Jack boot on on your
face if you don't do what they want and
if the Jews don't do what they want but
I'm happy to say that for the first time
in Israel and knesset
there is not one Progressive nor was is
there one leftist in the knesset and the
Jewish people in Israel couldn't be
happier and feel that they've been freed
from slavery
that's fine you said it what is the what
is the joke that you were going to tell
me
the the the people with mental health
issues say there's insane and out saying
oh I see I'm sorry I'm sorry thanks I
thought you were making a serious
statement about it okay I get it
now listen Roseanne let me ask you the
most difficult question in the world
apparently what is a woman
how much do I weigh
no what is a woman
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breaths hang down to her stomach and who
has uh a prolapsed uterus from giving
birth to five ungrateful little bastards
who have never had to work for a thing
in their goddamn life that's what a
woman is
I see and how do the ungrateful little
bleeps uh how do they react when you say
things like this about them
oh they laugh they have good senses of
humor you should hear the
about me
you wouldn't believe they have the worst
jokes about me
what's your life grandson
I was going to ask you Roseanne you've
obviously been through the the mincer a
bit in recent years but how are you and
yourself I mean you happy you have a
happy life
yes I do I have a joyous Wonderful Life
uh it's a bit hot down here but yeah I
have uh I own my
I own myself and my soul and my space
and my uh
ethereal thinking and my art and I have
a wonderful loving family and my
mother's still alive she's 89. she's a
bit of a libtard but I overlook it but
uh and so are my gay brother and my gay
sister and all of my family actually are
libtards but you know I just pray for
them and love them
do they do the same for you do you think
oh they think I'm completely off the
they think I went off the the planet oh
yeah but they love me they just don't
they just don't engage but you know when
you're sitting there at Passover and you
know you're drinking the the cups of
wine to celebrate you know leaving Egypt
and what are your libtard uh nephews or
I mean grandsons whatever it is he
stands up what about the Egyptians who
were slaughtered shut the hell up
[Laughter]
you know here's the thing Roseanne is
that obviously you like saying you know
outrageous things and I like that about
you actually I think more people should
be doing this I love life um but but it
seems to me you don't necessarily fall
out with even your nearest and dearest
over it have we all just got two
sensitive are we too over offended
should we just be able to say outrageous
things and then have a drink and a laugh
with each other
check it out pierce the people that are
saying everything's offensive are
walking down the street swinging their
penises and kids face dress those are
the people who say shit's offensive
the [__] you know what I mean Jesus
hey hello
this is my advice to today's woman keep
your penis in your pants especially when
children are around women
Roseanne I think we certainly lived up
to the billing of uncensored uh thank
you very much indeed for joining the
show I appreciate it good to see you and
good luck with your tour which I know is
selling like hot cakes but I'm not
surprised